In this introduction, we've covered what
machine learning is and what it can do.
We've covered how to evaluate whether or
not you're ready, and
what you're going to cover
over the next several months.
Now it's time to get started.
In the introduction to this [INAUDIBLE]
we're going to cover some of the big
picture ideas in machine learning.
You're going to hear
from Charles Isabel and
Michael Lipmann's
machine learning class.
You're going to hear from
Sebastian Thrune's intro to machine
learning class.
You'll hear from Ashok Goyal and
my knowledge based artificial
intelligence class.
These are all materials meant to
give you a big picture view about
what machine learning is and
what it can do.
And that's really the learning goal for
this particular unit of
this nano degree program.
You don't yet need to worry about
how you do machine learning.
You need to start off with
understanding of what machine learning
actually can do.
So, try and
focus on what machine learning can do in
these first few videos.